[Applause]
[Music]
forty-five years it's been 45 years
since China and Australia established
diplomatic relations since then things
while they've changed a lot
[Music]
modern china was founded in 1949 with
this with these words John Warren man's
anchee life the Chinese people have
stood up it was an assertion of
sovereignty it was an assertion of pride
and we stand up and so we say Italian
man's unchi life the Australian people
stand up
[Music]
through all these years both countries
have maintained one of the most fruitful
controversial and interesting
relationships in the world a
relationship based on stories about
money
spies accusations infidelities and many
many conflicting interests because in
all honesty if we're talking about a
relationship between two people instead
of two countries we'd have a great
script for a Latin American telenovela
but obviously this well this is visual
politics so let's get right to the point
shall we
today China is Australia's main
commercial partner their purchases
represent about a third of all
Australian exports eight times more than
exports to the United States see in 2015
China and Australia signed a free trade
agreement and today their trade
relations exceed a hundred and fifty
five billion dollars per year and not
only that China is also becoming an
incredibly important investor in
Australia a country where one in 20
people are Chinese among them many
millionaires who decided to find a safer
place with more guarantees for their
assets and their lives such as a scale
of trade that financial markets have
long been of the view that the
Australian dollar is one of the best
proxies for bets on China itself
James Lorenson deputy director of the
Australia China relations Institute
of course this all has its consequences
we already talked about it here on
visual politic Australia has broken
records and has not had a national
crisis for almost 30 years sounds pretty
amazing right well the great Chinese
take off had a lot to do with all of
this success
therefore it's easy to understand why
when the Lowery Institute an important
think tank in the country asked
Australians last year which relationship
was more important than the one with the
United States or the one with China and
the result but it was a tie this is
despite the fact that relations with
their North American friends aren't very
close indeed however in spite of this
romance the fact is that 2017 was not a
year of love for Australia and China
check out what Bob Carr former Minister
for Foreign Affairs of Australia said on
the subject this year Australia declared
for torkoal war on China the words being
used by Australian leaders are the
harshest any time since diplomatic
relations commenced in 1972 with the
exception of comments at the time of the
TNM and crackdown the tone is harsher
than that of any other US ally including
Japan as you can see 2017 was a very
difficult year for both countries
relations so much so that a survey by
the Global Times one of China's most
popular newspapers determines that
Australia was the most hostile country
to China in 2017 and the truth is that
with Trump in the White House those are
really big words we can't continue to
allow China to rape our country and
that's what they're doing it's the
greatest theft in the history of the
world so what the hell happens what has
led to so much dissension between
Canberra and Beijing well let's have a
look at that shall we
[Music]
the storm
at first 2017 seems like it would be a
good year for China and Australia
economic relations wouldn't stop growing
Crump showing off his best diplomatic
skills hung up on the Australian Prime
Minister Malcolm Turnbull himself
further sinking his popularity in this
area of the world and the Australian
government even publicly supported China
replacing the United States as a main
member of the failed TPP the Pacific
free-trade agreement we can almost say
this in telenovela terms love was about
to triumph
however the good times didn't last long
and everything started to go wrong about
halfway through the year and it went
really wrong yes they have had clashes
before but nothing really major in
recent years the Australian government
has followed a strategy that basically
consisted of trying to balance their
position between Beijing and Washington
in economic matters it was all Beijing
and in security and defense matters it
was all Washington we already mentioned
on visual politic that Republicans
consider Australia to be the us's best
ally and so should be Australia is the
only country that has intervened in
every major US war and for years their
military relations have been so tight
that Australia has become the us as
spearhead in this area of the world the
Australian Prime Minister himself has
shown his great appreciation for the
United States saying the peace and
stability of her region has been enabled
by consistent u.s. global leadership
while that leadership would not have
been possible without the hard power of
fleets and armies its greatest potency
has come from the values which in
embodies through all the twists and
turns of history the United States has
stood for the values on which its great
Republic was founded freedom democracy
and the rule of law Malcolm Turnbull
bonds let's get back to the Chinese
matter see these words were pronounced
on June the 2nd 2017 that was the first
time an Australian Prime Minister spoke
so clearly in favor of Washington in a
speech which was also full of warnings
to China such a dark view of our future
would see China isolating those who
stand in opposition to or are not
aligned with its interests and then just
8 days later the media storm broke out
says espionage and foreign interference
against Australian interests is
extension several news organizations
reported on a single story the
Australian intelligence agency was
making very serious warnings about the
Chinese government's intentions to
influence Australian politics through
various means including purchasing
politicians journalists and scientists
or the surveillance and intimidation of
citizens belonging to the Chinese
community in Australia
the scandal when it was unleashed
suddenly news started to emerge on the
collaboration of Australian universities
and scientists with Chinese military
contractors for former politicians such
as the former Trade Minister Andrew Robb
who now works for companies controlled
by the Chinese government in exchange
for juicy salaries that amount to
hundreds of thousands of dollars and of
course the Australian security services
fear of Chinese espionage certainly
isn't new various Australian governments
have been blocking Chinese corporate
operations for years and have also
banned companies such as croire from
participating in deploying a national
broadband network this is all precisely
because of a fear of espionage or
excessive Chinese influence however
despite everything controversy and
tension had never gone this far media
reports have suggested that the Chinese
Communist Party has been working to
covertly interfere with our media our
universities and even the decisions
elected representatives right here in
this building in the Parliament Malcolm
Turnbull
on December the 12th 2017 soundest yari
Labour Party senator and one of the most
promising political figures in the
country was forced to resign because of
his ties to China I said earlier in his
statement that I am a patriotic
Australian I meant that with all my
heart
and I leave the Senate with nothing but
good thoughts for our country and for
our people among other things he was
accused of receiving money in exchange
for speeches that favored the Chinese
government's interests and even of
alerting a Chinese businessman linked to
the Communist Party that he could be
being investigated by Australia's
intelligence agencies and that his phone
could be tapped well scientists
collaborating with Chinese military
contractors University and filtration
paying journalists buying politicians
these accusations had been running since
the beginning of June the Australian
government denounced it publicly and
began modifying its legislation on
espionage treason emigration and on
financing political parties and this de
Feuer it looks like it's only just the
beginning it is no secret that China is
very active in intelligence activities
directed against us the consequences of
these cooling political relations can be
seen for example in foreign policy we
can clearly say that in 2017 Australia
has been favoring the United States like
never before but don't think that this
position has been unanimous among the
political class or at all in fact the
government doesn't seem to understand
the economic importance of the
relationship with China or the strategic
issues involved we're putting all of our
faith in our relationship with China
through the foreign policy lens of the
u.s. Paul Keating Australian former
prime minister and you know what given
the circumstances I think that this
entire debate on the position Australia
should take regarding China is quite
understandable
on the one hand many critics affirm that
there isn't enough evidence of the
Chinese interference that the government
denounces some we even say that this is
all a political operation fed by
Washington now on the other hands
breaking with China or at least being
this forceful with the Beijing
government isn't exactly easy for
Australia and they might be asking well
why is this well check this out China
defends itself without this entire
political crisis China has been very
strong of course they have denied all
accusations and have even said that this
entire campaign is based on racial
prejudice and anti Chinese paranoia this
paranoia they've claimed is turning into
clear hostility towards the Chinese
community in Australia itself Chinese
diplomats warned students in Australia
to stay alert to safety risks after
spate of attacks yes these types of
messages may seem exaggerated especially
because the truth is that beyond a few
posters in one university or another
there seems to be no evidence of this
acclaimed danger but although this claim
shows us how things are it's also kind
of a warning because clearly it isn't
good publicity
allow me to explain myself here Chinese
students account for four out of every
ten foreign students in Australian
universities and they spend 18 billion
dollars in the country every single yeah
it seems that Xi Jinping's government
wants to make it very clear that it is
willing if necessary to play in economic
terms as a pressure measure this is
something that by the way they have used
recently with both South Korea and
Taiwan and we aren't only talking about
students here but also about tourists
and investors for example in recent
years the luxury sector has experienced
a huge economic boom in Australia and
you know why well listen to this
students tourists and Chinese residents
in Australia are responsible for up to
two thirds of all luxury retail sales in
Sydney and Melbourne and how about
another example
China's direct investments in Australia
have multiplied not by 10 not by 20 but
by 32 in just nine years so as you can
see slowing down this entire process
could translate into a lot and that is a
lot of pain for the Australian economy
but dear viewer that is simply the way
things are so far the Australian
government remains faithful to its close
relationship with Washington the United
States seems to have secured an alliance
that it's essential for their interests
in this area of the world and for their
military industry in recent years
Australia became one of the us's best
customers and in the next decade they
expect to spend more than a hundred
billion dollars renewing their armed
forces where American contractors have a
big advantage
[Music]
however there are more than a few people
meant by people hearing in politicians
businessman and citizens who ask
Australia to remain neutral and protects
its national security without having to
make so many public accusations so now
the question becomes what how is this
story going to end well one of the most
fruitful relationships in recent years
be at risk well any time is going to
tell but now it's your turn where do you
think Australian politics should turn do
leave us your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey as I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
you did please do hit that like button
below and do not forget to subscribe to
this channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching and so we say Italian man's
ante like the Australian people stand up
it is no secret that China is very
active in intelligence activities
directed against us